am freitag steht eine gemeinsame übung
vom bundesheer und feuerwehr auf dem
fliegerhorst promx of screen langen
leben in niederösterreich auf dem
programm
geübt wird einmal mehr die
brandbekämpfung aus der luft
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
betont in ihrer rede die wichtigkeit der
reibungslosen zusammenarbeit zwischen
bundesheer und feuerwehr am heutigen tag
steht der zusammenarbeit im mittelpunkt
eine die perfekt funktioniert der
zusammenarbeit zwischen dem
österreichischen bundesheer unter der
feuerwehr die erprobt ist die aber
dennoch auch immer wieder geübt werden
muss und wenn die eine übung gesagt hat
werden müssen wegen krone ist es umso
wichtiger dass jetzt auch sozusagen
nachzuholen an diesen verschiedenen
standorten und dann auch vorbereitet zu
sein
vorbereitet zu sein im katastrophen gibt
wird sowohl das beladen mit wasser als
auch der punktgenaue abwurf des
löschwassers und das mit einer beladen
tc 6 im löscheinsatz und einem blackrock
helikopter
natürlich auch thema bei dieser übung
die anschaffung der neuen leonardo a b
169 im helikopter in diesem sinne möchte
ich mich heute die geschäfte von
bundesminister wirklich recht herzlich
bedanken
ich bin den letzten tagen sehr viel
unterwegs wieder gewesen
landauer auf land ab und überall wird
dieser ankauf der hubschrauber als sehr
sehr positiv begrüßt mir persönlich ist
es ein großes anliegen heute ein danke
zu sagen eine ministerin eine
ordentliche anschaffung noch die wir
brauchen und es möglicher sinn macht und
über cellectis hüfter bevölkerungs hilfe
der feuerwehr und genau hier am so
wichtigen stützpunkt für unsere
luftstreitkräfte genau hier im
fliegerhorst promos ski werden sich
sechster dieser neuen hubschrauber auch
ein finden die wir gemeinsam mit italien
beschaffen